well the big lie on college campuses for
decades has been that
the characteristic that defines america
above all else
is racism uh and and
so you have this cultivation of a victim
mentality
where to be a female on a college campus
is to be at risk of one's life
whereas in fact there's nothing more
privileged than being
an american female anywhere but on an
ameri on a college campus are you
kidding me
i mean the whole place is run by females
to its utter
uh you know destruction or to be a
under urm as the as the jargon goes and
i hear today that somehow
uh acronyms are now racist i didn't get
the explanation but i'm not surprised
because everything is racist
but to be a urm which is an
underrepresented minority it's also to
be at risk of one's life
notwithstanding the fact that every
single college
with any kind of selectivity ties itself
into knots to admit as many blacks and
hispanics as possible
with test scores that would be
automatically disqualifying if they were
presented by whites and asians
uh so this idea that racism is and
sexism
are the things we should be thinking
about most and that define everything
and are the reason to tear down western
civilization
that now is the driving force
in the in the world at large
what do you think if you had to grade
the professional
class at this point if you had to grade
the experts because i think
actually the next coming crisis that
we're going to have when we you know now
we just go from crisis to crisis or at
least you know two crises to another two
or whatever it is
is that i think that a huge amount of
our
experts have completely lost all
credibility
when you see videos of fouchy saying
masks don't do anything
then wear a mask now two masks maybe
kinda
and then you know biden another hundred
days
federal mask mandate why should the
people in montana be living under the
same rules as someone in metropolitan
new york city
just sort of the elite class do you
think that they've sort of done
irreparable damage to themselves
no i don't know well
from an objective point of view yes but
but
what one has learned uh over this last
two years or so and we knew that
beforehand
is how profoundly powerful
once pre-existing conceptions are and
worldview
so i don't think fauci is at all
discredited
in that very large portion of the
population that views the new york times
as
as
gospel truth and you know i you're an
optimist and you think that most people
are
are uh skeptical of of the
liberal worldview and ideology
i'm not so sure about that and right now
certainly
the liberal elites are in the seat of
power
and you know the vote for biden as far
as i was concerned
was sadly a vote for safetyism
it was a vote for uh turning
america's back on its history of of
entrepreneurship and risk-taking and
rationality
and a sane attitude towards uh what life
is about
you know trump got a lot of voids but
biden got more
and and so i i don't know i i think that
the whole world is as andrew sullivan
said we're all on campus now
and um this this
ideology is very powerful the more
people who graduate from college
the harder it's going to be to turn
things around and yet there were plenty
of people we've talked about it before
telling telling you and i i mean i
remember when when we did an event i
think at berkeley together
saying oh you guys are making this up
this is it'll just stay on college
campuses and then what do they always
say
then they'll go out to the real world
well apparently the real world
didn't have uh many safeties equipped
well the big lie on college campuses for
decades has been that
the characteristic that defines america
above all else
is racism uh and and
so you have this cultivation of a victim
mentality
where to be a female on a college campus
is to be at risk of one's life
whereas in fact there's nothing more
privileged than being
an american female anywhere but on an
america on a college campus are you
kidding me i mean the whole place is run
by females to its utter
uh you know destruction or to be a
under urm as the as the jargon goes and
i heard today that somehow
uh acronyms are now racist i didn't get
the explanation but i'm not surprised
because everything is racist
but to be a urm which is an
underrepresented minority it's also to
be at risk of one's life
not withstanding the fact that every
single college
with any kind of selectivity ties itself
into knots to admit as many blacks and
hispanics as possible
with test scores that would be
automatically disqualifying if they were
presented by whites and asians
so this idea that racism is and sexism
are the things we should be thinking
about most and that define everything
and are the reason to tear down western
civilization
that now is the driving force
in the in the world at large in the
united states are you worried are you
worried that the backlash to what you
just said will
actually start a new type of racism
when the average white kid or asian and
you've written a bunch
about this when the average asian kid is
going to have to consistently
score quite literally sometimes 20
percentage points higher
than the average black or latino kid you
could see why
someone would become racist not not you
should not become racist but
the system will have reorganized things
in a way that will
that will breed resentment
absolutely and uh it's only a matter of
logic
all you have to ask is well why does
every other group get identity politics
and not whites i'm you know whatever you
view of that statement
as a logical matter now i guess they
have the whole argument about
well blacks can't be racist because they
then define racism to be
something accompanied with by power but
if you're a working class white uh you
don't really feel like you've got a
whole lot of white
privilege but you know right now there's
a professor
uh in florida who is
under enormous pressure he may have been
fired
for talking about black privilege and
frankly he's absolutely right
again if you're if you're applying to
google right now
and you're a black engineer you've got
it made
you you know you can just write your
ticket you can ask for your salary
same if you're applying to be a black
chemistry professor at berkeley or
caltech
or harvard uh they've the
the welcome mat is open for you black
privilege is
real and so it is quite logical for
whites to say or asians to say but
asians are
kind of allowed ethnic identity but
if if they can somehow claim to be
oppressed as well and there's a it's
very weird what goes on with
asian identity where they kind of want
to be students of color and then the
administration says no no you can't be
students of color because you're too
academically successful but
you see this at uc berkeley where they
want the victim status
but yeah it's maybe it will happen it's
it's a
question of sort of the trump
deplorables versus the
elite whites and how much they can
suppress that but
it is arguably bubbling
along under the surface i fear that i
know your answer here but are you
surprised at all to now see that not
only
has this basically decimated the
universities but we're seeing this now
every well basically in every blue city
where now
all of even the private schools are
being infected
with all of this that every the charter
schools of course the public schools
but basically schools that were the
elite schools of new york city
uh are now instead of having
um you know uh score based
uh admissions we have equity-based
emissions
they're going to destroy their own
schools
well this has been going on for a long
time and you know sort of the
one of the rules of media is you have to
pretend like
something you're saying is for the first
time i mean i wrote an article
years ago decades ago about elite prep
schools like andover and exeter and
in new england uh that were already
back in the 90s embracing
multiculturalism and and
telling their black students that they
must think of themselves as oppressed
and
putting chips on the shoulder of
everybody minority student
but it it certainly is getting worse and
what i've
been researching for a while now and
keep getting distracted by other things
but which breaks my heart
to pieces uh is the assault right now
on the thing i love most in life which
is classical music
and what i've been noticing is that
there's not a single
guardian of our great traditions of art
whether it's a museum director
or in case of music an orchestra
conductor orchestra manager
a superstar singer or soloist
certainly not the classical music press
which is
willing who is willing to defend
this tradition of such sublime
expression of
of extraordinary variety
of human experience and and
uh communication from the charge that it
is defined by
racism and white patriarchal power it is
ludicrous there's a madman
at hunter college which is one of the
city university of new york colleges in
new york city
a music theorist who's involved in a
very big spout right now
over a viennese music theorist known as
called heinrich schenker
and this this hunter music theorist
philip ewell
is mad he he defines everything in
classical music
as a function of white maleness so he he
says well beethoven
you know he's a he's an okay composer
but the only reason we think of him as
great is because he's white and male
this is insane this is insane but it's
happening
everywhere everything is being torn down
and the people who have been given the
privilege
of defending and passing on this
inheritance
are cowards and they have all
rolled over and played dead and said of
course
ours our inheritance is racist and we
are now from here on in
gonna make decisions based on the
trivialities
of gonads and melanin if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell